I think we've got time for one more call
that why don't we go to oh I don't know
how about the eight one six area code I
like the sound of that caller from the
eight one six area code what's your name
and where you're calling from my name is
Anita and I'm calling from Kansas City
awesome what's on your mind Anita um
what part was that I was just asking
what you wanted to talk about today okay
sorry em my questions are something you
brought up in a recent video about
Donald Trump being severely uninformed
about the civil war and Inter Jackson
and you kind of touched on you know the
rising sentiment in the u.s. these days
that education is an overrated metric by
which you know of course is the compas
competency can be evaluated for working
in the government or even other fields
where it's important to know things
absorb is long-winded but my question is
do you in your everyday life when you're
not listing to show you find yourself
engaging in conversations or debates
with people who don't value facts and
knowledge or do you tend to conserve
your energy for more like fruitful in
deference yeah I tend to conserve my
energy I mean let me put it this way
there would be no shortage of
opportunities for me to have
conversations which we could
characterize as debates with people who
don't seem to value what the facts
actually are and tend to think much more
about you know how they feel something
is versus how it actually is
but I've said this before I mean I get a
lot of politics on the show so it's very
rare that I talk about politics outside
of the show and every time I mention it
Pat someone will write in and say how
dare I not be willing to talk about
politics outside of the show when I
should be blah-blah-blah-blah-blah like
listen I'm doing the show you know what
I mean I can't talk about politics 24/7
so I tend to reserve most of my
political discussion for the program I'm
willing to discuss politics outside of
the show but only with people who are
informed on the issues even if they
disagree with me but if they just don't
follow the news every day if they don't
have the background knowledge they don't
know the
three and the implications of the
policies that they support I'm not
willing to discuss any why not take it
as an opportunity to inform them because
if they're going to disagree with me
during the whole time it's just not
worth it to me yeah we're not going to
agree on anything that's fair you say
you guys are agreeing to disagree now I
am getting orders but you're just you're
just basically refusing to even figure
out whether you might agree to do not
even engaging in the discussion yeah I
don't blame you I really don't I know
every time I say it people get mad but I
don't know I need a my a bad person
because of that no I don't think you are
because I often find myself having to
shut down political conversations yeah
in like any social situation I find
myself in just because people like start
an argument or a debate if we want to
call it that that's because they want to
hear themselves talk and they want to
you know like scourge through the point
you're making to find a weak spot so
they get like you know they could be
like actually though this is what I
think so I do find it like fruitless and
I don't like to engage in it because
like I don't know people don't like that
when I'm like hey guys let's not talk
about this no I understand it and listen
the biggest the best part is Anita in
Kansas City doesn't think I'm a bad
person and I think for that we can all
sort of be at least a little bit good
thanks so much for the colony to really
appreciate it
have a nice day all right take care and
on that note pad why don't we go to a
break and then we'll be back we will
deal with some audience questions
including do I believe that swear words
should ever be censored